c'est le fléau des vignes cette année le
mildiou ce champignon qui s'attaque aux
feuilles et aux fruits il bénéficie du
dérèglement climatique puisque la pluie
et les températures douces c'est la
recette idéale pour son développement en
Touraine des parcelles de Chinon et de
bourgueuas sont particulièrement touchés
le syndicat des vins de Chinon estime à
30% les pertes engendrées par la maladie
mais seules solutions pour s'en
débarrasser traiter les vignes une
mission pas toujours simple pour les
cultures en biodynamie qui n'utilisent
pas de produits de synthèse reportages à
Cravant les coteaux avec Aurélie Renaud
des grappes grignotées par le champignon
et des feuilles claires se met de tâches
le mildiou est là sur les 17 hectares du
domaine Lambert ce sont les vignes
situées en plaine qui sont les plus
touchées par le champignon pionniers de
la biodynamie le domaine ici réalise des
traitements naturels on est plutôt sur
une partie on va empêcher le milieu
s'installer sur les jeunes failles donc
on va être avec un peu de bouillie
bordelaise comme on connaît pour les
tomates du soufre et de l'argile donc
l'argile va nous servir à durcir les
feuilles c'est la partie blanche qu'on
voit là il va nous servir à assécher à
éviter justement que le champignon
puisse s'installer se développer et des
tisanes donc tisanes prêle et des
écorces de sol aussi sur certaines
parcelles ici on a perdu entre 10 et 30%
du rendement la crise débute fin juin
avec les orages et se poursuit avec une
forte hygrométrie tout au long du mois
de juillet les traitements préventifs
ont dû être multipliés afin de stopper
la prolifération du champignon
l'objectif est simple protéger les
jeunes feuilles pour éviter les
problèmes de photosynthèse afin
d'emmener le fruit jusqu'à sa maturité
une situation inédite sur un mode
tropical voilà et donc là ça on a tous
tous ces biens en même temps quoi et il
suffit de il suffit de peu de choses
pour le vidéo il suffit de se louper de
d'une journée ou deux par rapport à un
traitement on n'a pas trop fait
attention aussi à mon on est dans la
plaine de Cravant on avait au mois de
juin on a eu des brouillards le matin il
y avait de la brume et de la brume c'est
et ça c'est le midi ça lui suffit il y a
même pas besoin de beaucoup d'eau ça
remonte sur les feuilles là par c'est
foutu quoi il y a des gens qui qui en
perdent un petit peu ils ont voilà un
peu petit enfin moralement c'est dur
quoi avec les pluies prévues cette
semaine les vignerons devront encore
lutter contre le mildiou le soleil fera
son retour le weekend prochain il
asséchera les vignes